je suis heureuse de vous retrouver là
l'équipe dynamique compétente dans une
autre vie Président je les ai je les ai
beaucoup côtoyés et je suis très
heureuse en tout cas de vous retrouver
aujourd'hui alors ce que je voulais dire
c'est que j'ai lu avec beaucoup
d'attention
le rapport sur l'enjeu foncier très bien
vraiment excellent rapport par contre il
y a une proposition qui a retenu mon
attention c'est celle qui porte sur les
occupations illégales qui fleurissent en
Guyane et à Mayotte donc c'est la
proposition 19 vous avez suggéré la mise
en place de procédures d'alerte entre
tous les acteurs afin d'accélérer
l'efficacité en Guyane vous le savez les
installations illégales n'ont cessé de
prendre de l'ampleur sous la pression
migratoire et ma question est simple
savez-vous si ces procédures d'alerte
ont été mises en place pour une réaction
plus rapide des forces de l'ordre parce
que les agriculteurs en souffrent